Tach zusammen, Jack Pop hier.
Die EM steht endlich vor der Tür und auch
bei uns dreht sich heute alles um die schönste Nebensache der Welt…
…nämlich Physik.
Und Fußball natürlich! Das habt Ihr Euch gewünscht, ganz besonders Tillmann. Der wollte wissen, ob diese irren Torschüsse aus den
Anime-Serien rundum Captain Tsubasa auch im echten Leben möglich wären.
Und auch wenn ich jetzt nicht so fußballbegeistert bin, aber Captain Tsubasa stand natürlich
auch in meiner Kindheit auf dem Fernsehprogramm. Wie war es bei Dir?
Ging mir auch so. Auch die die Kickers habe
ich gern geguckt, aber spielen kann ich gar nicht.
Aber bei zu Tsubasa habe ich vom Feeling her ein gutes Gefühl.
Und deswegen gucken wir uns heute gleich drei
dieser Schüsse an, und zwar den Fire Shot,
den Tiger Shot und Miracle Drive Shot.
Ein herzliches „Gut Kick“ in die Runde
und los geht’s!
Okay, Henry, sind wir ehrlich. Wir haben einfach zu wenig Ahnung von der Materie, um jetzt
hier einen auf Fußball Experten zu machen.
Aber wir dürfen jetzt nur nicht den Sand in den Kopf stecken.
Auf gar keinen Fall.
Wir haben uns tatkräftige Unterstützung
geholt, nämlich den YouTube Fußballexperten
schlechthin, Manu Thiele ist heute mit dabei! Der kann uns gleich paar Sachen erzählen.
Lass uns mal mit dem Tiger Shot anfangen.
Das ist der Signature-Move von Kojiro Hyuga,
einem der ärgsten Konkurrenten von zu Tsubasa. Und er hat einen richtig krassen Schuss drauf.
Der ist so hart, dass dabei sogar der Ball
platzen kann und Tornetze reißen. Da können
wir gleich mal unseren Außenreporter fragen. Manu, hat es irgendetwas vergleichbares schon mal im realen Fußball gegeben?
Hi Henry, hi Jack!
Das ein Ball platzt kommt tatsächlich hin
und wieder vor. Zum Beispiel hier im Bundesligaspiel
zwischen dem FC Bayern und dem 1.FC Köln. Da hat Daniel van Buyten einen Freistoß getreten
und plötzlich war der Ball kaputt.
Auch ein zerschossenes Tornetz haben wir schon
gesehen, zum Beispiel hier 2017 beim Spiel
zwischen Schalke 04 und Mainz 05. Sead Kolasinac
war dafür verantwortlich. Oder hier im Ausland, bei einem Elfmeter des
Kolumbianers Harold Preciado. Also ja, es
ist sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass ein Ball platzt,
oder das ein Tornetz kaputtgeht. Aber es ist
tatsächlich möglich.
Es scheint also, dass dieser Tiger Shot jetzt
gar nicht so weit hergeholt ist.
Es hat mich beim Schauen der Videos total
überrascht, denn eigentlich sind Fußbälle
sehr, sehr stabil. Es gibt Leute, die haben
einen Ball einmal in eine hydraulische Presse
gelegt, da brauchte es 5.000 Newton, bis dieser Ball platzte.
Und das ist so, als ob man eine halbe Tonne
Gewicht auf den Ball obendrauf legt.
Und in der Presse kann der Ball ja auch nicht weg, der hat ja so ein Gegenstück und auf dem Platz ja schon.
Genau. Auf dem Platz müsste der Fuß des
Spielers noch eine viel größere Kraft aufbringen. Und das schafft Fuß und Bein von einem Spieler eigentlich nicht.
Jetzt haben wir aber das Video gesehen.
Es ist ja offensichtlich passiert. Was da
los, Materialfehler oder?
Materialfehler sind eine Möglichkeit. Aber
ich habe noch eine andere Idee. Denn guck
Dir das mal ganz genau an. Der Ball platzt
nämlich nicht, als Spieler den abschießt,
sondern erst als ein zweiter Spieler reingrätscht und der Fuß dieses Spielers den Ball berührt.
Ich vermute also, dass der Ball jetzt den
Stollen dieses zweiten Spielers berührt hat
und der die Kraft ausgeübt hat. Jetzt spielt
nicht nur die Größe der Kraft eine Rolle,
sondern auch die Fläche auf die sie wirkt.
Und das ist das, was wir als Druck kennen,
nämlich Kraft pro Fläche. Und wenn jetzt
also die Kraft dieses Fußballers auf eine
sehr, sehr kleine Fläche wirkt, dann wirkt
diese Kraft viel, viel punktueller und dadurch
steigt der Druck sehr, sehr stark an.
Und wie hoch kann der Druck dann so werden?
Leute an der Sporthochschule Köln haben mal typische Kräfte gemessen, die Spieler auf Bälle ausüben.
Und die sind darauf gekommen,
dass das bis zu 4.000 Newton sind.
Wenn wir das jetzt einfach mal beispielhaft in unserer Formel einsetzen und annehmen,
dass der Stollen eine Fläche von 1 cm² hat,
kommen wir auf einen Druck von 400 bar.
Das ist schon ziemlich viel. Ein Hochdruckreiniger
schafft normalerweise 100 bar und ich kann
mir vorstellen, dass der Kunststoff des Balls
diesem Druck eben nicht mehr standhält.
Das heißt also, die Kraft des Spielers alleine reicht nicht aus. Es braucht ungünstige Umstände und einen zufällig guten Treffer.
Ganz genau. Sonst würden wir ja auch ständig sehen,
das Bälle platzen. Sehen war aber
nicht. Denn die sind ja genau dafür konstruiert,
dass die echt viel aushalten. Das haben wir
auch an dem Experiment mit der hydraulischen Presse gesehen.
Kojiro Hyuga bräuchte also, damit Bälle
platzen, den Zufall als Support. Aber jetzt haben wir noch das Tornetz. Könnte das denn wenigstens reißen?
Das können wir ausrechnen. Dazu brauche ich die Masse des Balls und die Geschwindigkeit.
Die Masse des Balls notiert die FIFA.
Jetzt für die EM zugelassen ist ein Höchstgewicht von 450 Gramm. Bei der Geschwindigkeit bin
ich überfragt. Das geben wir mal an Manu
Thiele. Manu, was war denn die krasseste Schussgeschwindigkeit?
Den Rekord für den schnellsten Schuss im
Fußball hält bis heute der Brasilianer Ronny.
Ihr kennt ihn mit Sicherheit noch von Hertha
BSC, da war er einige Zeit lang. Vorher hat
er bei Sporting Lissabon gespielt und dort
im November 2006 dieses Ding hier abgeliefert.
Bei diesem Freistoß wurde eine Geschwindigkeit von rund 210 km/h gemessen. Also dieses Ding war wirklich pfeilschnell.
210 km/h? Henry so schnell fahr ich nicht auf der Autobahn, das ist schon krass.
Das ist ziemlich krass und ich kenne auch das Video. Dieser Wert taucht auch überall im Internet auf. Da hat Manu vollkommen recht.
Aber mein Physikerkollege Metin Tolan hat
dieses Buch geschrieben - zum Thema Physik
und Fußball - und hat das Ganze mal durchgerechnet. Er ist zu dem Ergebnis gekommen, dass es eigentlich
unmöglich ist, Bälle auf so eine Geschwindigkeit zu bringen. Das liegt am Energie- und Impulserhaltungssatz.
Metin Tolan kommt zu dem Ergebnis, dass die maximale Ballgeschwindigkeit das Vierfache
der Anlaufgeschwindigkeit der Spielerin oder des Spielers ist. Das heißt, wenn Ronny jetzt
mit 210 km/h abschießt, müsste er also mit
50 km/h und mehr angelaufen sein. Das schafft nicht mal Usain Bolt.
Ja, echt krass. Aber warum steht denn der Wert dann überall? Also was haben die denn da gemessen?
Wie das genau gemessen wurde, weiß ich auch nicht. Aber vielleicht kann die Community ja weiterhelfen.
Stimmt. Dann spielen wir den Ball mal zu Euch. Wie kommen denn diese Spitzengeschwindigkeiten
und Rekorde zustande? Wie haben die das gemessen? Die sind ja auch teilweise schon älter.
Wenn Ihr eine Ahnung habt, dann lasst mal einen Kommentar dazu da. Würde ich mich freuen.
Wir müssen trotzdem mit einem Wert rechnen. Was setzen wir da jetzt ein?
Wir nehmen eine typische Geschwindigkeit von Elfmetern oder Freistößen. Das sind so 130 km/h.
Jetzt brauchen wir noch die Zeit, die
das Netz braucht, um den Ball wieder abzubremsen,
von diesen 130 km/h auf 0. Da nehmen wir an, das sind 0,1 s.
Wenn wir das dann in die Formel einsetzen:
F=m*a beziehungsweise F=m*Δv/Δt kommen ungefähr
eine Kraft von 163 Newton. Und das hält so
ein Netz locker aus. Also die Hersteller geben
an, dass die Netze typischerweise 1.000 Newton reißen.
Verdammt, Henry. Erst hatten wir kein Glück
und dann kam auch noch Pech dazu. Also für
den Tiger Shot aus Captain Tsubasa müssen wir festhalten: Grundsätzlich ist die Darstellung
richtig. Bälle können platzen, Netze können
reißen. Aber eben nicht, weil der Spieler
so viel Bums dahinter hat, sondern das sind
halt unglückliche Umstände oder Materialfehler.
Leider ja.
(Was schätzt Du, wie viele km/h waren das? 500!)
Dann kommen wir jetzt mal zu dem Wunsch von Tillmann, dem Fire Shot. Den beherrscht ein anderer Widersacher von Tsubasa, nämlich
der deutsche Spieler mit dem sehr deutschen Namen Karl-Heinz Schneider. Hier zu sehen
bei einem Länderspiel gegen Japan. Der hat
etwas Krasses drauf. Der schießt den Ball
so, dass er dann beim Fliegen in Flammen aufgeht.
Da müssen wir Tillmann gleich mal enttäuschend. Das geht nicht...
Och Henry, nicht einfach so trocken. Wir sind noch Science vs. Fiction. Komm, wir müssen eine Lösung finden, zumindest für Tillmann.
Also was bräuchte es denn, damit es funktioniert?
Da müssen wir uns erst mal angucken, ab wann
der Ball überhaupt anfängt zu brennen. Bälle sind heutzutage aus Kunststoff und diese brennen
so ab einer Temperatur von 300°C.
In dem Video sieht jetzt so aus, als ob der
Ball wegen der Luftreibung und der komprimierten Luft anfängt zu brennen. Das hatten wir schon
in unserer Sonic-Folge. Da haben wir gesehen, wir brauchen extrem hohe Geschwindigkeiten, dass das funktioniert.
Wie hoch müsste die Geschwindigkeit dann sein? Da gibt es doch bestimmt eine Formel.
Da gibt es natürlich eine Formel für!
Und zwar die, für die sogenannte Totaltemperatur. Mit der kann man jetzt berechnen, wie schnell
die Luft um den Ball herum strömen müsste, damit alle Energie dieser strömenden Luft
in Wärme umgewandelt wird. Und diese Formel habe ich hier schon vorbereitet.
Die steht jetzt hier oben und ich habe sie
bereits nach der gesuchten Geschwindigkeit v umgestellt.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, was in dieser Formel
drinsteht. Hier steht cp, dass ist die spezifische Wärmekapazität der Luft bei konstantem Druck.
Das gibt an, wie viel Wärme die Luft speichern kann. Die hat einen Wert von 1005 J(kg*K).
Uff. Dann steht hier das T0 drin. Da setzen wir
unsere Entzündungstemperatur ein, 300°C.
Und das T, das ist die Umgebungstemperatur.
Ein entspannter Sonntagnachmittag beim Fußball, sagen wir mal 20°C.
Und jetzt setzen wir einfach mal alles ein
und rechnen das Ganze aus.
Wenn wir das ausrechnen, kommt raus, das sind 750 m/s oder umgerechnet ungefähr 2700 km/h.
2700 km/h müsste der Schuss draufhaben. Lass mich das umrechnen. Das ist mehr als 20-mal
so viel, wie ein gewöhnlicher Elfmeter. Das
ist super viel.
Das ist super viel und das ist sogar doppelt
so viel, wie ein Überschallflugzeug hat.
Tillmann, es tut mir mega leid aber es sieht
leider überhaupt nicht gut für Dich aus.
Ich sag mal, die Situation ist aussichtslos,
aber nicht kritisch. Pass auf.
Wenn wir diesem Karl-Heinz Schneider jetzt
einen Feuerwehranzug verpassen und seine Umgebungstemperatur
massiv erhöhen, zum Beispiel in einem Ofen, und uns der Entzündungstemperatur des Balls
annähernd, auf 299,4°C, dann würde die
Schussgeschwindigkeit von 130 km/h sozusagen
ausreichen, um diese 0,6°C Differenz zu überwinden und den Ball im Flug zu entzünden. Tadda!
Sehr gut! Tillmann, das hast Du Deine Lösung!
Zugegeben, sehr skurrile Umstände aber so
würde der Fire Shot funktionieren.
Aber Sport im Feuerwehranzug ist vielleicht
auch ganz interessant, fällt auf jeden Fall
das Aufwärmen dann flach. Die Frage ist nur, wer macht so einen Blödsinn?
(Komm, gib Gas!
Endergebnis 1:1:2)
Damit sind wir im großen Finale angekommen, nämlich beim Signature-Move von Tsubasa selbst.
Das ist der Miracle Drive Shot.
Dabei wird der Ball angedreht und wenn der
dann auf dem Boden aufkommt, dann ändert der ganz spontan und ganz krass seine Richtung.
Und das verwirrt die Torhüter natürlich
total und die können dann nicht mehr reagieren
und das Ding landet im Kasten. Henry, was
sagst Du dazu?
Das geht physikalisch schon. Also wir sehen das in diesen Videos ziemlich gut, beim Tischtennis
oder beim Handball. Das Ganze funktioniert,
weil die Reibung der eigentlichen Bewegungsrichtung entgegenwirkt,
wenn der Ball aufkommt. Wenn der Ball nämlich mit Spin aufkommt,
ist die Bewegungsrichtung der Balloberfläche nicht die, in die der Ball gerade selbst fliegt,
sondern diese Flugrichtung überlagert sich
mit der Drehrichtung des Spins. Und so wird
der Ball entgegen dieser überlagerten Bewegungsrichtung abgelenkt und beschleunigt.
Aber warum sehen wir diesen Effekt vor allen Dingen bei den anderen Sportarten? Ich vermute,
weil da der Ball eher von oben nach unten
gespielt wird und beim Fußball eher von unten nach oben.
Das heißt, er ist im Fußball nicht unmöglich,
aber eher ungewöhnlich. Fragen wir den Außenreporter. Stimmt das, Manu?
Ja, das stimmt. Diesen Effekt sehen wir hier
sehr selten. Aber es gibt noch andere Spins,
die spielen beim Fußball eine wichtige Rolle
und sorgen immer mal wieder für richtig schöne Tore.
Der weltberühmte Freistoß von Roberto
Carlos gegen Frankreich fällt mir da ein.
Wo man erst denkt, dieser Ball geht meilenweit am Tor vorbei und dann zieht er doch noch
rum und landet im Netz. Man kann solche Flugkurven sowohl bei Schüssen mit dem Außenrist,
wie jetzt hier bei Roberto Carlos, oder auch mit dem Innenrist, wie zum Beispiel hier von Lionel Messi, beobachten
2019 in der Champions League gegen Celtic Glasgow gelangen ihm gleich zwei
Tore mit diesem Stil, in nur einem Spiel.
Das ist jetzt noch mal eine ganz andere Nummer,
das finde ich jetzt auch als Fußballnoob
ziemlich spannend, erklär mir das. Woran hat es gelegen?
Ja woran hat es gelegen? Das fragt man sich
nachher immer, woran hat es gelegen!
Hier liegt es am Magnus-Effekt und der Magnus-Effekt
ist benannt nach dem deutschen Physiker Heinrich Gustav Magnus. Der hat herausgefunden,
dass sich um den drehenden Ball eine mit drehende Luftschicht ergibt und diese sich drehende
Luftschicht bremst die an dem Ball vorbei strömende Luft auf der einen Seite ab und auf der anderen
Seite beschleunigt sie die: Und das führt zum sogenannten Bernoulli-Effekt.
Der besagt jetzt, dass der Druck in schnell
strömenden Fluiden geringer ist, als in langsam
strömenden. Und jetzt haben wir die Situation, dass auf der einen Seite des Balls der Druck
groß ist, auf der anderen Seite kleiner und
jetzt versucht die Luft diesen Druckunterschied
auszugleichen. Und es gibt eine Kraft, die
den Ball in Richtung der schnell strömenden
Luft drückt und ihn ablenkt. Um diesen Effekt zu erzielen, muss man den
Ball beim Schuss entweder mit dem Inne- oder mit dem Außenrist an der Seite anstreifen. Dann bekommt der Ball den Spin.
Total easy, das schafft doch jeder…
(Jetzt ins rechte ober Eck zirkeln!
Gar nicht schlecht!)
Jeder, der nicht so ein Noob ist wie wir,
der kriegt das hin. Das heißt, im Fußball
sind Spins und drehende Bälle nichts Ungewöhnliches. Es gibt krasse Flugkurven, die sich dadurch
ergeben. Theoretisch ist sogar der Miracle
Drive Shot von Tsubasa möglich.
Fassen wir zusammen. Bei zwei von drei Schüssen macht uns die Physik hier mal wieder einen
Strich durch die Rechnung. Henry, schönen
Dank auch.
Ja, bitte. Aber es ist nicht so schlimm, weil
das sind die Schüsse von Tsubasas Gegnern.
Stimmt! Und der Miracle Drive Shot von Tsubasa selbst haut ja hin, also alles perfekt.
Aber sagt Ihr doch mal. Was ist denn eure
Lieblingsszene oder Lieblingsfolge aus Captain Tsubasa?
Und an welche Animes habt ihr so
richtig schöne Kindheitserinnerungen?
Lasst doch mal einen Kommentar dazu da. Vielleicht ist ja auch was dabei, was Dr. Henry Holland-Moritz
mal für Euch wissenschaftlich checken kann. Immer wieder gern!
Großer Dank geht auf jeden Fall an Manu Thiele, unseren Fußballexperten. Ohne den, so ehrlich
müssen wir sein, wir keinen Meter gekommen wären. Danke auch an die Feuerwehr Jena und
den Universitätssportverein. Von denen habe wir die tollen Anzüge bekommen und wir durften
auf deren Rasen Quatsch machen. Ich wünsche Euch auf jeden Fall eine richtig schöne EM.
Und eins dürft Ihr natürlich auf gar keinen
Fall vergessen, nämlich…
Abonnieren!
Und die Glocke drücken!
Wir sind solche Idiotien!
In diesem Sinne? Ich habe fertig.
(Okocha!)
(Jawohl!)
(Der sieht aus, wie einer von der Kinderfeuerwehr!)
(Henry, wie würde ein Physiker-Verein heißen?
Schrödingers Vollidioten!)